[Music]
thank you
foreign
program I'd like to know I Am David
Salazar I'm the newest member of the
ministerial team here in the ministry
and I am blessed to be here with two
distinguished guests one of them is
actually well they're not guests they're
actually members of the team Pastor
Stephen Bohr who is our president and
founder of six concealed and Pastor Sam
Murray who is also a speaker of Citizen
seal and does a lot of administrative
work here in the ministry thank you
gentlemen to for being here with us
today and we'll start today's questions
that are going to be very very
interesting very important but first how
about we have a water prayer plaster
Murray if you can join us or lead us in
prayer
shall we pray father God we praise you
and thank you for your word which is a
lamp unto our feet and a light that
shines brightly on the path before us we
thank you Father that there are
questions but there are also answers to
those questions that can be found in
your word so as we open your word we
know that spiritual things are
spiritually discerned so we ask now for
the mind of Christ for the
superintendents of your holy spirit so
that the words that we say the things
that we bring forth will be but your
will for your people as they have sent
in questions give us Godly answers we
praise you and we thank you in Jesus
name amen amen before we start with the
questions I want to remind our audience
to remember to send your questions this
program is really becoming uh my
favorite too as I am learning from my
colleagues here they know more about the
questions and the answers but this is a
really good program for you to join us
send your questions at TV at some tv.org
you may send your question and we'll do
our best to answer them from the
scripture spirit prophecy and we'll
always try to do our best in getting to
them we may get a lot of questions so
please be patient sometimes but we would
like to get them back to you and answer
the questions you may have so let's
start today we have a interesting
question to begin with with and I'll
read this question and let one of you
gentlemen get the answer
it says here dear pastors hello I have
stayed in a place that where I found
both Adventists and not Adventists
living in the same yard however the
challenge is that the house belongs to
an Adventist it has been very difficult
to talking to the non-adventist tenant
about the Sabbath or why God's word
forbids idol worship it also seems
worsened by the fact that the Adventist
says that the non-adventist lady becomes
sensitive when addressing such matters
we do our best to keep the Sabbath holy
however I'm still worried and often
became become stressed about it what
should I or we do
so this is a question that comes to us
it seems that this particular person is
living in a home in a setting where
their the home is shared with somebody
else and they're not Adventists what are
they to do in this matter of you know
keeping the Sabbath or helping this
other person that none of this
understand the concepts of the Sabbath
I think there are many people who
believe the only way to share the gospel
is to preach it
um there are many ways to to share the
gospel uh one is to live it
and let your words and your Deeds match
if you're in a situation where you find
someone who is resistant to the
preaching of the word
um then live the life before them I
remember Ellen White responding to a
pastor he said I want to be a more
effective uh Communicator of the word so
I'm thinking about lengthening my
sermons from 45 minutes to an hour and a
half I said she said no she said what
you want to do is preach less you know
preach less and live the life amen so
the multiplication of words is not
always the most effective way to
communicate the gospel particularly when
you have someone whose walls are up who
has put up barriers live the life uh do
kind things for them insert Christ when
you can but don't be limited by the
preaching of the Gospel there's also
other ways to share Christ with others
in in the world and give a good example
of Sabbath observance in a very
difficult situation yes uh you know it's
very difficult to live in an environment
where uh where they're close together
and you have one group that are not
keeping the Sabbath and the other group
that believe believes you're supposed to
keep the Sabbath it becomes very
difficult but not impossible right right
is important to remember that the
Sabbath commandment tells us that we are
to keep it holy and those that are under
our care or under our
um I guess uh under rotation under a
roof uh you know they are to also keep
the Sabbath yes but in this particular
case since they're sharing a a home you
know we have to remind our our viewers
or the person that sent this question
that we are to limit ourselves to our
household and those that we are under
our care and we have to in matters of
conscience respect we cannot dictate the
consciousness of anybody and in this
case if that woman that lady is a you
know worships Idols or has another type
of idea of what worshiping God is uh we
have to respect and allowed only the
light as pastor Murray mentioned at the
beginning you know our testimony or or
behavior how we keep this sabbath really
be the influence and I believe that in
due time God will use that testimony to
bring that person around we've seen that
in many cases in in our own experience
as how the Lord has used not what we say
so much not how we want to make somebody
act like we do but really how we conduct
in in love in showing Christ in our
actions what brings people to the desire
to learn more and then be open to the
idea of the Sabbath you know the the
comment that you made about
within your Gates you need to make sure
that the Sabbath is observed that's a
Biblical concept right the fourth
Commandment says remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy six days you shall
labor and do all your work but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
your God in it you shall do no work you
nor your son nor your daughter know your
uh male servant nor your female servant
nor your cattle nor your stranger who is
within your Gates
so if this is a shared situation where
each has their own realm so to speak
right then you need to make sure that
you're keeping the Sabbath in your realm
but you can't obligate the other person
to keep the Sabbath the way you do
exactly exactly good questions all right
so we have another question
if you don't lead us with the next
question
alrighty um this is from
I guess it's IFA effa
um
and I am sure that ordaining women as
pastors and Elders is not a Biblical
sound Doctrine
my question is
what about the ordination of women as
deacons is it biblically excuse me
biblically sound
Hmm this is a question I think that I
would like Pastor board to start the
answer obviously there is something
important that we have to recognize here
but password if you don't mind sharing
some of your thoughts on this question
okay there's a lot to say about this I
just want to mention first of all that
the
I don't know whether I should use this
word ordination
of women as deacons was approved I
believe at the St Louis General
Conference session it was approved by
the World Church
I I hesitated about using the word
ordination because Ellen White never
uses the word ordination to refer to the
setting aside of deaconesses or deacons
or deacons right the matter
um she always uses the expression
setting apart
with the laying on of hands she uses it
for medical missionaries and she uses it
also for deacons and deaconesses but
whenever she refers to the ordinary to
setting aside pastors and elders
she uses the expression laying on of
hands but she also uses the word
ordination
so you know maybe we could actually take
a look at those statements about uh D
deaconesses being set apart and also
medical missionary doctors being said
set apart so that we can see the
distinction should we do that I think we
should yes and well we look for them
let's remind you know as Pastor Warren
mentioned the Biblical
term that is used for deacons is found
in
um acts 6 verse 7 verse 6 actually acts
6 verse 6 and it says there that the
apostles you know they when they chose
the seven deacons they pray for them and
they lay their hands on them it was it
was uh like a consecration ceremony
does not use the word ordination or or
does not use it that term to make a
specific you know a use for the deacons
it really just means consecrating them
for that service setting that part think
that's where we should really think of
when we talk about the terms of decans
and the kinesis
Paul and white only use the word
Deaconess
once in all of the hundred thousand
pages that she wrote
and she uses the word Deaconess in the
context of Elder A.T Jones
who was counseling women who had marital
problems and Ellen White wrote to him
and said you should not be counseling
women
who have marital problems you should
refer this to the deaconesses of the
church
now here's a statement where Ellen White
is describing the work of a Deaconess
but she doesn't use the word Deaconess
but by the job description we know she's
talking about deaconesses this is in the
book Daughters of God page 102 and
actually the original source is
reviewing Herald July 9
1895. and notice she doesn't say that
women who do these things should be
ordained
this is how it reads women who are
willing to consecrate
some of their time to the service of the
Lord should be appointed to visit the
sick looked after the young and minister
to the necessities of the poor they
should be set apart to this work by
prayer and the laying on of hands in
some cases they will need to counsel
with the church officers or the minister
that's a clear distinction between their
job and the minister of the Church of
course but if they are devoted women
maintaining a vital connection with God
they will be a powerful good power for
good in the church this is another means
of strengthening and building up a
church we need to Branch out more in our
methods of Labor not a hand should be
bound not a soul discouraged not a voice
should be hushed let every individual
labor patiently or publicly to help to
to help forward this Grand work place
the burdens upon men and women of the
church that they may grow by reason of
the exercise and thus become effective
agents in the hand of the Lord for the
enlightenment of those who sit in
darkness so that's clearly a description
of the deaconesses of the church they're
part-time workers they're not minister
right the other the other example is
that Ellen White referred to as the
setting aside of the deacons by the
laying on of hands and I'm not going to
read the statements it's in Acts of the
Apostle page 89 she doesn't use the word
ordinary ordained or ordination but she
says set aside by the laying out of
hands also in councils on health
page 540 she refers to the setting aside
of medical missionary doctors by the
lane on of hands and she explains why
the reason why is if they are set aside
by the laying out of hands they will see
that their responsibility to stay as
missionary doctors is a great thing
because they've been set aside for that
purpose and so Ellen White made a clear
distinction between uh you know setting
aside deacons and deaconesses and
medical missionary doctors aside by the
laying on of hands and the word
ordination as it applies to elders and
it is applied it applies to pastors as
well so you know it's kind of It kind of
doesn't make sense to say well because
we set aside whim uh women as
deaconesses by the laying on of hands
well you know we can set aside women uh
to be elders and pastors of the church
by laying in of hands you're dealing
with two different Church offices there
you go and you know saying that you're
setting aside the deaconesses does not
necessarily mean that you're that you
can set aside women as
um you know as functioning functioning
as uh uh elders and as pastors of the
church absolutely when I was pastoring
uh and we brought in our new uh
group of officers for the year we had a
consecration service for them as
officers of the church because they were
in service positions they're serving the
church uh and so I I I I think it's
right and fitting that we consecrate
them but consecration is not ordination
there are two different services and
that distinction ought to be maintained
but you have women who are going about
doing work of the church visiting caring
for people uh uh I think it is fair and
just to consecrate them to that to that
to that duty but then also you've got
Sabbath School people and other kinds of
offices that that uh I think it is fair
and just to consecrate them also so we
did that early in the year praise the
Lord and I think that kind of answers
the question very well what you both
have shared uh the ordination that word
really is not you space for prophecy or
the Bible when setting up deacons or
deaconesses we can say that is a
consecration service that is should be
done and there's nothing wrong with that
laying of hands upon them by the
ministers that's what I think is right
now unfortunately there is this
confusion with this term ordination as
it seems that is only used for somebody
that is going to be dedicated full time
to the gospel and to the ministry uh and
that of course according to the Bible is
men uh not not done for women now um
any other thought that you want to bring
to this I think we're pretty pretty
clear yeah the bottom line is you cannot
justify the setting setting aside of
deafnesses by the laying on of hands to
uh
ordain
uh women elders and pastors yeah I mean
that's a stretch you can't use one the
setting aside of one function to justify
the setting design of the other function
true that's where we that's where we are
making a mistake and following a path
that is not set in scripture or Spirit
prophecy so um that's important thank
you all right we have the next question
who would like to read the next question
I think it's a very important question
we have to answer well since it's
addressed to Pastor Bob I'll read it in
uh in his hearing all right dare I say
praise the Lord
hello Pastor board and it also mentions
uh Daniel uh God bless you for your work
I have a question uh this is Joshua
keganda from Uganda now we have a
growing Church in Uganda amen
preaching there at the union office in
Uganda recently or or during covid I
came across someone who was saying that
the Earth is flat you know that is
gaining a sentence I'm hearing more more
about the Earth being flat uh that's a
new diversion distraction in these last
days that was not a problem the problem
was he was saying that the issue the
issue is salvational that you can be
saved by not believing it you can be
lost forever when I believe that that is
believing that the Earth is a globe will
hinder our entrance to heaven which is
which flat or globe and is it
salvational
well the first one is easy to answer
I think Columbus dealt with that in
1492. you know that's been the answer to
that is several hundred years old the
Earth is round uh and uh we've had
people leave the Earth and look back and
see that it's right uh so we know it's
around if there's any doubt when the
when the astronauts look back at the
Earth from the Moon they said oh it's
around of course the flat earthers say
that uh that that's doctored
you know some people don't even believe
that the United States has gone to the
Moon
that is Juicy we are a watch in
conspiracy theories of which the church
is not immune is it salvational
well it cannot be because it's not true
your salvation cannot be based on a lie
of course it's not true so
um it's a shame that that there are
there are Christians who are promoting
this or propagating this but it's not
it's not true and so how can one
salvation be based on something that is
not true right so it it it it cannot be
selfish
the Bible does speak about the circle of
the Earth
right that's actually what I was going
there Isaiah 40 I think verse 22 yeah it
says that he seated upon the circle of
the earth and the inhabitants thereof
are grasshoppers and yeah not not the
flatters but that's the table
why you know
the one thing that is salvational
there is salvation in no other amen but
Jesus Christ amen salvation does not
hinge on whether the Earth is square or
round so you know the answer to the
question whether it's salvation is uh
absolute no
but you know is into of course
absolutely right the the thing I've been
thinking finding curious is you know why
would someone you know
um really come to this to perceive these
theories as truth or as you know even
consider them to be salvational and I
believe it's really stepping away from
the truth from the word of God when you
when you don't spend time in God's word
you're gonna be willing to listen to
ideas Concepts things that come along
your life that are not really true
they're just lies yes and you're gonna
be accepting a lie as truth because
you're not spending enough time in the
word of God but as you spend time in
God's word the holy spirit will teach
you all things and we'll lead it to all
truth and we'll you'll find that
something like that comes along you'll
be like no that's just not true yes you
know so it's a certain sound yeah
exactly sounds bad so hopefully you know
Joshua you listening to this program you
can actually uh realize that it's not
important really this is not salvation
issue just stick to the word of God and
help that other person to really spend
more time in the God's word and he
probably come to the same conclusion you
know in a in a broader context in these
last days one of the things that are
going to be happening there are going to
be those who dis diminish important
parts of the word of God then will be
those who will add to the word of God
they will make things salvational that
are not salvational they will base their
salvation on things that that are not
salvational
um you know there's there the The Ten
Commandments obedience to the word of
God as stated is salvational but we add
a lot of things that are not we make
them religious tests of faith that are
not tests in faith and that that seem to
be proliferate proliferating in these
last days that people are adding things
and making them test the faith that are
that are not test of faith yeah yeah
absolutely all right so let's go to the
next question uh I think we have once I
think a time for one more
the question is hello pastors thank you
for your ministry and being Watchmen on
the tower my question is what is the
difference between sanctification and
salvation by works
what is this question this is Adriel
Lewis I think the answer is so very
simple
salvation by works is where through your
own efforts you try to keep the law
sanctification is when the Holy Spirit
is in your heart and is a natural flow
of having the holy spirit in your heart
you uh perform works so in other words
do you do it in your own strength
or the holy spirit that dwells in you is
he causing you to do these works yeah I
think that's very plain very very true
it is the indwelling of the spirit that
motivates you that moves you to do good
works if you try to generate
righteousness by your own efforts that's
legalism and of course there's no
there's no sanctity or salvation in that
but if Christ is in your life you're
gonna do because you cannot help but do
because Christ is generating the power
the motive Force to do those good things
if if I love Christ I I work for him
because uh first of all I love to do it
and secondly because he's in me and he
works through me you know Ellen White
states that there are going to be two
false ideas that will basically uh
characterize the world at the end of
time
number one that you can be saved by your
works and number two that you can be
saved in your sins you know uh history
functions on the basis of the pendulum
it swings way right and then it swings
way left and it swings back again
um the bottom line is that during the
1260 years
the papacy taught people they that they
could be saved only by their works by
doing pilgrimages and by by the you know
doing the rosary and all these things
you know they could work their way to
heaven
these days uh the pendulum has swung to
the other side yes which is the idea
that you know God God's grace is so
great his love is so wonderful that no
matter what you do he's going to save
you in your sins
and so uh both of those are aberrations
of the true Gospel of the Bible and you
cannot be saved by what you do and you
cannot be saved in your sins you're
saved because you accept Jesus Christ as
your savior who then dwells in your
heart through the Holy Spirit and the
Holy Spirit performs The Works from
inside not something for us from outside
yeah absolutely yeah it is you know
interesting to know that oftentimes
false religion
will pull you or bring you to the
concept that you can save yourself by
doing something even those that are
under the idea that you know
the love of God Is So abundant you you
can basically sin and continue to live
in and be saved they usually point to
the you know when you confront them to
the concept that how come you're not
following the law of God if you love God
so much and you know you're in that
region with the Lord how come you don't
follow the law they always bring back
the concept that oh I do love I have
loved my heart and even though I may not
keep the Sabbath holy or whatever I love
to give money to the poor and and so in
one way or the other you come to that
idea that you do enough by your Works to
be saved there's a there's a it's a it's
a very interesting uh concept of false
Security in even in those that are
thinking that they are not necessarily
asked to follow their God's law that it
is by showing love and in essence doing
something that they are saved it is
really the heart that has to be
connected with God and that as possible
mentioned very clearly you know the
concept have been transformed within
that will enable you to have that
Victory and do the works of the law and
enjoy them and we have pleasure in them
and you'll see sin for what it is you
know you're not going to have that that
desire to do the same but really you
know even though you might have to work
with your problems or your Tendencies or
your you know shortcomings you're really
gonna ask the Lord please Lord help me
change me Purify Me Make Me Better made
me you know be like you and that's what
really is gonna ultimately
take you to the position of living
reflecting Christ in your life and in
your uh everyday you know experience
yeah so it's important to keep that in
mind so using the words of James
faith without works is dead and works
without faith is dead indeed so we're
not really saved by works alone we're
not saved by faith alone
we're not saved by faith Plus work we
are saved by a faith that works amen
through the power of the holy spirit
amen amen and I think we have to keep
this we think between you know before
our people to understand that you know
it is not a perfect obedience that is
God some somehow checking on you you
know to see if you are perfect it's
really how much you depend on the Lord
how much you're willing to surrender to
him every day that God can work in you
that decide to the good and to follow
his Commandments and you know put his
heart he wants to write his law in our
hearts that's what ultimately what he
wants to do to have that reflection of
his own character in ourselves amen amen
yeah well I think that's pretty clear
our time is just about running out so I
don't think we have time for another
question unfortunately we don't but
remember we want to remind your our
audience to keep sending your questions
we have uh the desire to answer them and
we'll do our best to do this remember we
have a lot of questions that we want to
get to so have patience give us a little
bit of a chance to get through them but
we'll promise you that as long as you
send them we'll try to get to them and
answer them until time may God bless you
thank you once again for watching us and
may the Lord keep you and protect you
wherever you may be
[Music]
thank you